[Music]
the long muscular alimentary canal is
one of the finest systems in our body
however the process of digestion cannot
really get completed without chemical
digestion of the food just like
mechanical even chemical breakdown of
food is extremely important and which
part helps in this process well there
are organs called glands scattered
throughout the digestive system
these help in secreting the necessary
enzymes for the process of digestion
just like every part of the alimentary
canal has a specific role in the process
of digestion similarly each gland
secretes digestive juices which help in
completing the process let's learn about
these important glands in detail in this
video the ones near the beginning of the
alimentary canal are the saliva glands
next on the list are the gastric glands
placed on the stomach then we have two
both of which are placed near the
stomach and the small intestine
yes we're referring to the liver and the
pancreas these four major glands help in
secreting the digestive juices that are
specific for the breakdown of
carbohydrates proteins and fats let's
begin with the saliva glands first we've
always heard about the fact that
digestion begins in the mouth any idea
how well it's due to the secretions from
the saliva glands these include the
collection of three pairs of saliva
glands the parotid glands the
submandibular glands and the sublingual
glands the parotid glands are situated
here these can be located roughly around
the upper cheeks on either side the next
pair is of the submandibular glands
isn't the name self-explanatory
mandibles are the jaws especially lower
jaws in mammals so these pairs are
located on either side of the lower jaw
on similar basis can you help me locate
the sublingual gland pair
give it a shot that's a right guess the
term lingual heads in associating with
the tongue so this pair of glands is
located in the region below the tongue
each of these help in secreting the
saliva collectively the saliva secreted
by these glands contain the enzyme
called the salivary amylase and what's
this usefully well saliva amylase helps
in breaking down carbohydrates partially
so mixing the food with salivary amylase
helps in the partial breakdown of
carbohydrates in the food
now after carbohydrates we have proteins
on our list how are they broken down
well just like carbs proteins are also
broken down partially first that is
taken care of by the gastric glands
present in the stomach this specialized
cells in the gastric mucosa of the
stomach secreted juice known as the
gastric juice this contains mainly the
enzyme pepsin apart from the other
components the enzyme pepsin helps in
breaking down proteins partially now
comes the turn for the fats but fats
cannot be broken down they are
emulsified that is the larger fat
droplets are converted into smaller ones
and this is aided by the next gland on
our list this is the largest gland in
our human body any guesses which organ
are we talking about that's right it's
the liver the liver secretes an
extremely important secretion called the
bile however it supplied by the
gallbladder now what could this be
well can you notice the small structure
here this is nothing but the gallbladder
it's like a personal assistant of the
liver the gallbladder takes up the
responsibility of releasing the required
amount of bile as and when required
emulsification of fats marks the
completion of partial breakdown of the
consumed nutrients now it's time to
break the nutrients completely so who
comes for the
rescue its the pancreas now this is one
of the most important glands in our body
as it helps in secreting digestive
juices as well as hormones pancreas is a
het recurring gland which secretes the
pancreatic juice and even the hormones
that help in regulating sugar levels in
the blood but for now we will focus on
the pancreatic juice as veer amidst the
digestion process the pancreatic juice
is a mixture of three major enzymes
these enzymes include pancreatic amylase
trypsin and lipase the pancreatic
amylase is the one that helps in
digesting carbohydrates trypsin breaks
down proteins and lipase helps to break
down the fats completely getting back to
a process the time which is the pulpy
fluid passed down from the gastric
glands and mixed with the bile now gets
mixed with the pancreatic juice which
helps the food digest completely as the
food reaches here
the common duct carrying the bile and
the pancreatic juice pores in the
secretions which help process the partly
digested food further once broken down
the nutrients are all set to be absorbed
by the small intestinal cells as the
time enters the duodenum and moves ahead
this is how the various enzymes present
in the various secretions bring about
the complete breakdown of nutrients
present in our food the saliva glands
gastric glands liver and the pancreas
contribute in their own way to complete
the process of digestion
[Music]
you